>> Image editing software like Photoshop and apps like Instagram or
Snapchat allow you to apply visual effects to images.
You might be thinking why would I want to edit images in a browser?
>> It's a good question.
For one thing, most photos only exist in digital formats.
The computing power needed to process a single image is well,
pretty much negligible.
And doing things locally allows the user to make changes without a full
round trip to the server and back.
And most importantly, it's actually a lot of fun.
>> Yeah.
We might make an image black and white by averaging the red, green and
blue values.
>> Or we could invert the colors by assigning the pixels to the compliments of
their current values.
>> Or maybe we wanted to turn down the lights and turn on night vision mode.
>> We'll be working without the help of an external library.
But check the instructor notes for software packages and
applications to make advance photo editing easy inside the canvas.